Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je suis en lévitation.
Mais le plus surprenant,
c’est que vous l’êtes aussi.
Vous croyez être en contact
avec votre fauteuil, mais c’est faux.
Vous flottez au-dessus de lui.
Touchez le fauteuil devant vous.
Allez-y, touchez-le.
Êtes-vous sûr que
vous le touchez vraiment ?
Vous pensez avoir touché
le fauteuil devant vous ?
En fait, il ne s’agit que
de répulsion électrostatique.
Pourquoi ?
Au bout de vos doigts,
la chair est faite de molécules.
Ces molécules sont constituées d'atomes.
Et pour le fauteuil devant vous,
c'est pareil.
Ces atomes sont faits d’un noyau positif
et d’électrons négatifs
qui tournent autour.
Les électrons, de même charge électrique,
se repoussent les uns les autres.
Donc,
lorsque votre doigt va toucher
le fauteuil devant vous,
en fait, ce sont les électrons
qui se repoussent
sans jamais se toucher.
C'est la répulsion électrostatique.
Si nous étions précis,
nous devrions dire :
« Le nuage électronique des atomes
constituant les molécules
appartenant à la chair de mon doigt
rentre en répulsion électrostatique
avec le nuage des atomes
appartenant aux molécules du fauteuil. »
Évidemment, c’est plus facile
de dire : « Je touche. »
(Rires)
Si on analyse objectivement la situation,
jamais, je dis bien jamais, de votre vie,
vous n’avez touché et
vous ne toucherez quoi que ce soit.
Surprenant, n’est-ce pas ?
Cela veut dire aussi que jamais
vous ne pourrez rentrer en contact
avec les atomes de votre fauteuil
ou de votre voisin.
Y avez-vous déjà pensé ?
Si vraiment il y avait un contact
au niveau atomique,
il y aurait une fusion nucléaire.
Et là, ça serait catastrophiquement
explosif pour votre existence.
Sciensation.
Oui, vous avez bien entendu.
J’ai bien dit : « Sciensation ».
Quel mot étrange et surprenant !
Oser lier la science à une sensation,
mais où cela peut-il bien nous emmener ?
Confronté à une explication scientifique,
vous avez peut-être déjà ressenti
de la surprise, de l’étonnement,
de la fascination, de l'excitation.
Ce fameux « Waouh ! »
C’est ça, la sciensation.
De nombreux scientifiques ont vécu de la
colère face à une équation récalcitrante
ou à une expérience qui ne fonctionne pas.
D’autres ont pu ressentir une joie intense
grâce ou après des calculs trouvés
après longueur, lourdeur.
D’autres ont pu même être
séduits, charmés,
par une nouvelle formule
qui leur apparaît.
Subjugués, stupéfaits par une nouvelle
théorie qui vient juste d’être validée.
Bref, tout un monde de sensations.
Et vous aussi, ce soir, vous y avez droit.
Regardez votre voisin.
Allez-y !
Êtes-vous bien sûr que c’est lui
que vous voyez vraiment ?
(Rires)
Ce que vous voyez de votre voisin,
ce n’est pas directement lui,
mais la lumière qui réfléchit
à la surface de son corps.
Vous recevez seulement
des informations portées par la lumière.
Pour preuve, si on éteint les projecteurs,
votre voisin disparaît.
(Rires)
Plus d’information lumineuse,
plus d’existence.
Dans le noir,
pour savoir s’il est toujours présent,
il vous faudrait pouvoir le toucher.
Or, vous ne pouvez pas.
(Rires)
Je viens de vous l'expliquer.
Ha ha ha ! Qu’est-ce qu’on rigole !
(Rires)
Regardez une fois de plus votre voisin.
Êtes-vous sûr de le voir
dans son présent à lui ?
(Rires)
La lumière que votre voisin
vous renvoie possède une vitesse.
Une vitesse de 300 000 km/s.
Oui, vous avez bien entendu 300 000
kilomètres parcourus en une seule seconde.
En une seconde,
la lumière est capable de faire
sept fois et demi le tour de la Terre.
Totalement énorme.
La vitesse la plus rapide
de l'univers connu.
Elle a d’ailleurs la chance
d’avoir son petit nom personnel :
« C », pour « célérité ».
Et vous la connaissez.
On la retrouve dans une équation
célèbre d’Albert Einstein,
E = MC².
Quoi qu’il en soit,
si la lumière a une vitesse,
cela signifie que la lumière
venant de votre voisin
prend un certain temps pour
aller de lui jusqu’à votre œil.
Quelques nanosecondes,
quelques milliardièmes de seconde.
Mais dans l’absolu,
vous voyez votre voisin tel qu’il était
dans son passé à lui.
Jamais de votre vivant,
vous ne verrez quelqu’un dans son présent.
(Rires)
Si la lumière avait une vitesse de 1 m/s,
les gens à cinq mètres de moi me verraient
tel que j’étais il y a cinq secondes.
Si je marche cinq secondes sur la scène,
pour les gens à cinq mètres,
à cet instant, je serai toujours là-bas.
(Rires)
Ils voient mon passé
d’il y a cinq secondes.
Plus la distance augmente, évidemment,
plus la durée de parcours
de la lumière augmente aussi.
Puisque le Soleil se trouve
à 150 millions de kilomètres,
la lumière venant de lui met huit minutes
et 20 secondes pour nous parvenir.
Nous voyons donc le Soleil tel qu’il était
il y a huit minutes et 20 secondes.
Si j’étais capable de faire disparaître
le Soleil en un claquement de doigts -
ne vous inquiétez pas,
je n’ai pas ce pouvoir,
(Rires)
enfin... non -
nous serions dans le noir total
dans huit minutes et 20 secondes.
La Terre n’est pas comme le Soleil :
elle ne brille pas,
elle réfléchit la lumière du Soleil.
Supposons maintenant que je sois capable
de me téléporter instantanément -
donc plus vite que la lumière -
à des distances toujours de plus
en plus grandes de la Terre.
Plus je suis loin, plus je vois
la Terre dans son passé.
Je remonte le temps.
Je peux donc voir comme des photos
le Moyen-Âge,
l’arrivée de Bouddha,
les hommes préhistoriques,
les dinosaures,
et tout ce qui a pu exister
à la surface de la Terre.
Toute l'information concernant le passé
de la surface de la Terre se trouve
dans l’espace.
Pour l’instant,
nous n’avons pas la technologie
qui nous permet de nous téléporter.
Nous ne savons pas nous déplacer
plus vite que la lumière.
Nous ne pouvons pas rattraper
ces particules de lumière,
les photons, qui ont été réfléchies
à la surface de notre planète.
Mais réaliser que l’information
concernant le passé de la Terre
existe vraiment dans l’espace,
je trouve ça absolument fascinant.
Un jour, peut-être saurons-nous
rattraper ces informations
et nous pourrons enfin résoudre
ces fameuses énigmes historiques :
qui a tué Kennedy ?
(Rires)
Qui était dans le masque de fer ?
Ou encore la poule ou l’œuf ?
Revenons sur Terre et parlons de vous.
Je vous propose une fois de plus de
porter votre attention sur votre voisin.
Une vraie source d’inspiration
pour vous, ce voisin, ce soir.
(Rires)
Pensez-vous être capable
d’estimer son âge ?
(Rires)
Savez-vous de quoi
il est réellement constitué ?
(Brouhaha)
Si je m’approche
de la surface de votre peau
et que je zoome avec un microscope
très puissant, voici ce que j’observe :
un assemblage de molécules
constituées d’atomes.
En réalité, on ne voit pas vraiment ça.
Cette image n’est qu’une représentation
symbolique de la réalité.
Mais communément,
c’est de cette façon que l’on
représente les molécules et les atomes :
deux sortes de petites boules.
Les atomes sont donc
constitués d’électrons,
puis, en leur centre,
de protons et de neutrons.
Or, on le sait à l’heure actuelle,
les protons et les neutrons se sont formés
il y a 13,7 milliards d’années.
Eh oui !
Comme vous êtes constitués
de protons et de neutrons,
vous êtes là depuis le début de l’univers.
(Applaudissements)
Vous êtes vieux.
(Rires)
Même vous les jeunes,
vous êtes vieux, très vieux.
Ah ! si seulement vous pouviez
leur parler à vos atomes !
Ils vous diraient certainement
que vous avez été dans une étoile,
dans une plante,
dans un asticot,
et peut-être même dans Jules César.
Nous sommes donc constitués d’atomes
composés d’un proton et
de neutrons, donc d’un noyau,
puis d'électrons qui tournent autour.
Si le noyau était une balle de tennis,
les électrons tourneraient
à six kilomètres.
On voit bien qu’entre le noyau
et les électrons,
il y a du vide, beaucoup de vide.
Beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup.
Il y a 99,99999% de vide.
Vous êtes donc constitué
de 99,9999% de vide.
(Rires)
De là à dire que vous avez la tête vide,
il n’y a qu’un pas... que je franchis !
(Rires)
Car qui osera dire ici que vous
avez quelque chose dans la tête ?
D’ailleurs,
si l’on parvenait à rapprocher
tous les électrons de leur noyau
et qu’on les plaçait tous en un seul
endroit chez tous les êtres humains,
l'humanité entière tiendrait
dans une cacahuète.
Une cacahuète avec la masse
de l’humanité tout entière.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Comme je vous le disais,
les atomes sont souvent représentés
sous forme de petites boules.
Les protons, les neutrons,
les électrons aussi.
Pourtant, la réalité
est bien plus étrange.
Voici la célèbre expérience
de Thomas Young.
Elle a été réalisée pour étudier
la nature de la lumière,
puis celle des électrons.
Des électrons sont envoyés
à travers une fente
grâce à un canon à électrons,
un peu comme des balles de tennis.
Sur l’écran, derrière,
on observe les impacts.
Ils ont la forme de la fente.
Jusque-là, rien d’extraordinaire.
Si maintenant on utilise
deux fentes côte à côte,
voici les impacts que l’on observe.
C'est une figure d'interférence.
Et c’est exactement la même figure
que l’on pourrait obtenir
si l’on avait réalisé l’expérience
avec une onde,
de la lumière ou de l’eau.
Il semblerait donc
que l’électron se comporte
comme une balle, une particule,
s’il y a une fente,
ou comme une onde
lorsqu’il y a deux fentes.
Nous sommes en présence
d'un objet quantique.
Mais là où ça devient
encore plus perturbant,
c’est lorsqu’on tente de détecter
par quelle fente passe l’électron.
On sait le faire.
Mais dans ce cas, l’électron se comporte
à nouveau comme une particule
et on retrouve les impacts
avec la forme des deux fentes.
Le choix de l’expérience,
une fente ou deux fentes,
influe sur notre représentation du monde.
Waouh !
En son temps, cette expérience
a bouleversé les scientifiques
car ses résultats sont
complètement incroyables.
Je dirais même plus :
ils sont sciensationnels, n’est-ce pas ?
Ça va ?
Avec tout ce que je vous ai dit,
vous n’êtes pas en état de choc ?
Vous pourriez l’être !
Vous pourriez l'être.
Il y a d'autres façons de vivre et de
ressentir le monde qui nous entoure.
Les poètes, les écrivains,
les peintres, les sculpteurs,
les musiciens, les danseurs,
les mystiques,
nous offrent tous de magnifiques
perceptions de notre monde.
Mais la science n'est pas en reste.
Elle aussi nous donne un accès
à ce monde des sensations.
Elles sont de l'ordre du surprenant, du
grandiose, du stupéfiant, du vertigineux.
Intrication quantique, dilatation
du temps, relativité, multivers.
Vous voyez, ce soir,
nous n’avons qu’entrouvert la porte.
Si vous vous laissez
vraiment emporter, traverser,
par ce déluge de sensations
que la science peut vous offrir quand
elle décrit la réalité de notre monde,
et surtout, surtout,
si vous en prenez profondément conscience,
alors vous ne pouvez pas rester de marbre.
Vous vous transformez, vraiment.
Une connaissance intellectuelle
ne fait pas ça.
La sciensation le fait.
La science nous invite
à contempler notre humilité.
Avec elle,
notre vision du quotidien change
et lorsque l’humilité
se conjugue à l’intelligence,
n’est-ce pas la sagesse qui nous guette ?
Je vous laisse y réfléchir
avec votre voisin.
(Rires)
Bonne soirée. Merci. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)